well the vegas golden knights can get  back to work today this morning the nhl  said the team can start practicing again  on wednesday after the coronavirus  brought their season to a stop  games over the weekend and tonight were  postponed nice defenseman alex  petrangelo and three coaches are in the  nhl's covid 19 protocol they are  unavailable for the time being  the games that were lost were made up  february 13th and 25th  as of now the golden knights report  forward straight days of negative tests  that's a good thing  the night's next game is friday against  los angeles at t-mobile arena we have  the updated schedule for the knights at  8newsnow.com